my
Diggory so Angela
yesterday I shall open
flighty so high-level things above
well assalamualaikum warahmatullah
better care to bothers and sisters and
dear friends hope you guys are doing
well
before I start one appraisal expand what
Allah the most merciful the most trust
or praises glory and gratitude belong to
him for the works that we do now
Providence is as you guys know want to
get straight into it and I want you guys
to listen to me please carefully for the
sake of Allah without judgment to be
with this video let's put our judgments
to a side let's not think okay that's
brother Ali Dowell man's friend
there were hobby the wobblers this that
what like for the sake of Allah
let's put that to a side I'm coming to
you and want to speak to you as a
brother while lying he'd be like I want
to speak to you from a heart to heart
level for those who celebrate the Mawlid
and for those who don't celebrate the
moment you guys are my brothers and my
sisters we might differ
we might differ I don't celebrate it
personally I don't celebrate it I have
my reasons and evidences which I believe
is a strong to what I have seen right I
don't believe it but brothers and
sisters let's not make this a reason
that when you see me or when I see you
you say oh I'm leavin gonna give Salam
to a brother or I'm not gonna give Salam
to him because he's celebrating this
well like we shouldn't do this Imam
Shafi said that even though we differ on
a certain matter can't we at least be
brothers can we at least be brothers so
this the reason why I want this video to
inshallah to reach brother azzam and
obviously brother Harun will be watching
this and the reason why I I will be
addressing both for the brothers in a
way not that like they have much more
knowledge but knowledgeable than me and
I'm just a little guy without no
knowledge believe me I don't know and
I'm not saying this to be humble in any
way I barely started it I barely started
the Deen I try my best but that's
another topic and I just want to address
this issue because Imran is a brother
man he's a friend of mine and in the in
the times that I went through in my life
when I was kicked out of my house when I
first came to Islam may Allah bless him
he looked ass to me and I will never
forget that he's my brother and I love
him what light like I love him as much
as but I asked him you're a brother of
mine if I see you on the street while I
by Allah will come I will Salaam you I
will talk to you this is what this deal
is about the Prophet SAW Allah was
selling them said
I did not come for nothing but a perfed
good manners you two are brothers and
this video is mainly for fun for your
followers both of your followers and for
those who follow my works or whatever I
do because the problem really lies there
you two are doing videos now what we
need to understand is that you both want
both love the messenger of allah
subhanho wa taala
you both love him right and then no
matter what you different you both love
it and the work you're doing is you're
doing it with the attentions for the
sake of the Deen
but what I need to see is brother in
mine is my brother I have advised him in
private
in certain matters like we need to meet
this something clear
even though brother in Randers law class
to me may Allah bless him I love him to
bits but Alice want Allah says speak the
truth even if it's against yourself I
will speak the truth even if it's
against myself I'm not going to come
here and say oh brother Imran's my
friend or he's helped me he's done this
so I'm just gonna go out and speak
against somebody just because he's my
friend this will not be truthful of me
this will be arrogant for me it would
not be nice that's the reason why I've
spoken to him around certain matters I
said okey you know maybe a bit of good
manners will be there and I know brother
him at home delight his mush on his
manners I on point hamdulillah same as
brother Adams is well may Allah bless
both sides and both sides did have
issues with manners and talking to each
other the only thing that I'm going to
say from both parties having a debate
with each other brother as him and
brother Imran the manners could have
been a better beat could have been a bit
better and a bit more on point and apart
from that this is not what I'm here to
do let's put that to her side now the
followers of brother awesome or should I
say the followers the ones who celebrate
motive and the profit on or celebrate
Mawlid my dear brothers and sisters
there's certain comments that I saw
while I had he upset me so much he upset
me so much I'm looking and I'm seeing
what I'm seeing it really saddens me why
because backbiting slandering each other
over what last year when Imran released
that video regarding Mawlid now the
brother has the right to express himself
and say this is the reason why I believe
this now Imran doesn't do this by saying
you know what I'm going to release this
video to annoy the people
celebrate moded now brother Imran
genuinely from his heart because he
cares and to his evidences he think this
is a innovation he just did a video
brother asked him responded in the same
way by thinking by with his evidence
what he has people are there to judge
I'm not going to say right or wrong he
put forth his evidences to why he
believes it's not bitter now when this
video happened there was a lot of
conflict online and I was going to
Birmingham a couple of days after that
and the brothers in Birmingham who
celebrate mullet you engage in the model
celebrations were sending out frets in a
way no fly zone if you come to
Birmingham this will happen that will
happen obviously all praises belong to
Allah I'm like I'm not scared of anyone
in any way and I don't mean it's an
arrogant way but never without thinking
of millionaires I'm gonna put my hand up
to another believer or hit them never
may Allah protect me from that I would
never want to do that I went to
Birmingham there was a certain
individuals who were sending threats to
me but at another point there was
brothers who celebrate mullet and
brother and if I'm not mistaken two or
three brothers which I don't want to
mention by name invited mr. actually
less meat lab brothers and go for a
coffee can I said hamdulillah this
Miyake one lady we're not enemies to
each other I went to Birmingham city
centre we met like brothers they brought
me coffee
they treated me with respect even a
month ago the brother invited me to
Birmingham I was there and then I talked
to him and we went to his restaurant and
we sat down and talked like brothers but
the first time they invited me we sat
down I said aqui look this is my
evidence but this is why I prefer not to
celebrate this is me and the Braavosi
look lucky this is the reason why we
celebrate as a tacky let's agree to
disagree
yeah let's agree to disagree yeah I've
just said look this is my evidence I'm
not gonna put a gun to yet I'm not gonna
say a key better stop celebrate moulded
a key that's between you and Allah and
what I believe is between me and Allah
now what we need to understand all the
sisters is that humility
manners while light brothers and sisters
manage is so important these robbers
invited me we sat like robbers and we
talked and we agree to disagree and alas
we left it at that
I did not utter a single word of
disrespect to them they did not utter a
single word of disrespect to me why
can't we do this brothers and sisters
yes you might be passionate and you
might get upset does it give you a right
to automatically go and slander a
brother
oh he's this man is that man is this
names and what sadness means I even saw
certain brothers who look like their
student of knowledge backbiting and run
and I've also seen from Imran that I'm
gonna be honest when I'm in one side the
brothers who daughter Sarah married back
by some brother assam now brothers and
sister this is wrong one lie if you knew
the weight of slander backbiting you
would go and do repent repent now you
would go and repent now I just want to
make a few points importance of manners
well lie how important man is is this
their sisters who who are just based
having a little debate here not being
called prostitutes who had been called
where's that hot you're a hole you're
this you're that province over over
something that you disagree you come in
in sort of backbiting slumber a sister
just imagine if it was your sister like
how would you like come on brothers well
ladies let's come back to our senses we
are brothers we find that soul like I
said before if I saw brother as him on
the road do you think I'm gonna go
disrespectin one line ever a
characteristic of a believer is that
when you go and see somebody even if you
have a problem regarding matter of
Mawlid normal it whatever it may be when
you see the brother you will say
assalamu alaikum our key are you okay
can I buy you coffee no matter what is
your disagreement you would say you know
what you are a broth on this done at
least you will see that but what's
happen online openly backbiting and the
funny thing is this is turned into a
football match how when brother Imran
releases a video everybody starts having
yeah yeah he refuted by the awesome when
brother azzam
released the video then you have rose
from that Sena is destroyed in run
brothers and sisters have we look you
you know my father on Facebook I have
not made a single post about both sides
why because I'm just observing I'm
looking at both sides both evidences
right I'm a revert to Islam so I'm
looking at both evidence
is now what I need to understand is if
we are genuinely looking for the truth
we should not get upset when somebody
opposes our idea we should say hold on a
second firstly brother Imran may Allah
bless him he's involved in the dog work
what he does he's bringing for froggen
yes maybe the man has should have been
better yes let's see the manager to be
better on both sides but let's hear him
out what's you're about the same with
those who are listening brother azzam
now I was in rands video then I saw
brother asin's video then I watch
Imran's
a rebuttal to that then I watch brother
a soms I am watching both sides and I'm
just weighing it up now why can't we do
that if I went and said you know what
emmalin's my friend whatever happens if
I were to couldn't have not done that
good and I say you know what I'm just
gonna go whatever Imran post I'm just
gonna share it but the reason why I
didn't do that because I'm taking a
balanced approach I'm just trying to see
both sides of the story but what I
really really obsessed me is that
brothers can celebrate the molded when
brother awesome releases their video he
hasn't even watched it is two and a half
hour video one one-hour video 30 minute
video
he hasn't even watched it automatically
brother azzam has destroyed them or the
same thing happens from from the side of
the brothers who don't celebrate mullet
don't side with Mowgli oh he's destroyed
brother awesome this shows insincerity
why watch the video with an open mind
see the evidences weigh it up and make
your decision we have no right to put a
gun to it as a believe this or believe
that don't celebrate the mob we'll
celebrate the moment you are a human
being I won't ask you to intellect you
see the evidences make your decision but
without going on a rant even more what
lie I'm just asking it for the sake of
Allah we are brothers in Islam I said it
before I'll say it again
I don't celebrate moulded I believe the
evidence of strong bond is that this is
me personally but in no way why would
that give you a right to slander or
backbite me why would it give me a
reason to sound on back bite you because
you celebrate the moment like I said
before I have met brothers who celebrate
the Mawlid and when it comes to their -
look we disagree on the matter but when
it comes to manage they respect me they
invite me we talk now I just want to
finish off with this I'm going to give
you some narration from the prophet
sallallaahu Selim sallalaho aleyh was
seldom about the matters of manners
how important manners is and I like I
said before the Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him said I did not come for
nothing but to perfect good manners now
I'm going to share a narration from an
se bin Malik and I said bin Malik said
for the one I'm just paraphrasing by the
way and I said Malik said the one who
prays five times a day and prays extra
Sunnah for the one who fast in Ramadan
and fast extra the one who does or gives
in charity watches compulsory and gives
extra and does all these extra deeds but
has no manners with the people he will
enter the Hellfire the lowest part of
the Hellfire something on those lines
however the one who prays five times a
day nothing more the one who fasted
Ramadan nothing more
the one he gives in charity nothing more
but has good manners with the people
will enter Jannah now this is why the
reason why I mentioned this to you is
for you guys understand the severity how
important manners is and Abdullah
America said if I knew that a really
well-known scholar came near my city I'm
just paraphrasing like I said before and
I did not have a chance to meet him to
seek his knowledge I would be a bit
upset but if I knew a scholar who had
good manners very good manners and he
came and I missed him and I didn't get
to see him I would be very upset I'll be
so upset now
do you see how the impact that it has on
him the fact that he missed an
opportunity to meet the one that had
good manners and when in an adman would
give talks and lectures 30,000 people
would come 30,000 people would come to
see him do you know how many of them
will come to seek knowledge and how many
of them will come to learn manners
10,000 would only come to seek knowledge
the remaining 20,000 would come to just
observe a man admits manners how is his
manners with people how is he speaking
howdy conduct himself the Salaf assaleh
him they would teach their children and
they would say oh my son or my child it
is better for me that you learn one
chapter on manner manners then 70
chapters of knowledge this is what they
would teach their children what do we
learn from this
just think about it all the slander the
backbiting that you do against brother
Imran or brother assam over this matter
of this agreement is it worth it what
does it show about our manners against
each other and I want to tell you I want
to carry on and give you more narrations
who you guys to understand how important
manners is brothers and sisters and also
the Prophet Muhammad SAW Allah will send
him said for the one who has good
manners for the one who has good manners
and is good to the people around him the
Hellfire is haram for him I repeat for a
person who has good manners with the
people with the people around him his
neighbor's his friends the people around
this good conduct good manners he said
the Hellfire is haram for him is haram
brothers and sisters look what about her
aaron Ariz from the messenger the
Prophet peace be upon him he says you
know what is most likely to send people
to paradise but to be conscience of
Allah and have good manners with the
people and in another narration of the
messenger peace be upon him the biggest
the one of the biggest things that's
going to be the heaviest on the scale of
a on the day of judgement is the one who
worship Allah alone and had good manners
good manners good manners good manners
brothers and sisters how many times can
I repeat to yourself
good manners from with one another get
the heat out of your heart
two parties are debating with each other
yes I said both of them should have bet
better etiquette and better manners with
their dealing with each other yes but
brothers and sisters please when it
comes to the matter of manners being
respectful to each other less upstair
from standard backbiting
let's unite in that with this different
certain matters okay but let's not have
this mentality that when I see brother
Assam I'm going to talk about this to
him or when I see brother Imran I'm
gonna say this tune and probably sisters
I wrote you one thing listen to both
sides openly look at everything if
you're genuinely looking for the truth
whatever it is look at both sides
weigh it up and then make your decision
but if one side release the video
without even watching you're slandered
but without even watching
and you need to understand brothers and
sisters brother Imran if he's doing
something do you think he's doing it
cause he hates brother awesome do you
think he's doing this scene you know
what I'm gonna go on and on the people
who celebrate modeling today brothers
and sister I know Imran yeah I've spent
time with a guy I know him so the
brother in man he believes this
innovation so when he believes just put
yourself in issues you study the
religion exception look I knew thinking
okay there's people that's doing this so
let me just advise him just if you do
that advises him dude I'm trying to say
but he's just going out there for the
sake of the for the sake of all US want
Allah and His Messenger and selling in
silence providing his evidence for me
and you to do is what look at both sided
evidence wait up make our decision leave
the race rest allah subhanaw taala
problem says I don't want longer too
much once again ask you for the sake of
Allah we are brothers and brothers and
sisters in humanity
let's not backbiting slander one mother
one life for the sake of Allah touch one
end with this lap Imam Shafi said car
we'd be brothers and sisters even though
we disagree on a matter can we do that
one like that's all I'm asking for you
thanks for listening may lost 110 grand
you guys Jana share this with whoever
you think would benefit and please share
it in sha allah because
inshallah we can understand and learn
that man is so important let's not bad
by less not slander let's look at to
both evidences and make our decisions
may I just want to grant every single
one of you guys jaana like i said before
you guys are brothers and sisters love
you all for the sake of allah share this
video assalamualaikum I like mentholated
okay
you
shoo-shoo shoo-shoo